a mother is facing murder charges in the  death of her five-year-old daughter  thanks for staying with us at 6 30. i'm  denise valdez and i'm brian loftis an  arrest report neighbors telling police  kamiyah  taylor had been acting strange during a  welfare check police say taylor was  suffering  from a mental episode and searched the  house officers kicked down the door of a  locked room and found  a two-year-old standing next to her  unresponsive sister  the report says the ac the temp was at  95 the temperature in the bedroom  was 101 with the humidifier turned all  the way up  while being arrested taylor said quote  it was a necessary sacrifice  the youngest daughter is in cps custody  taylor expected  in court a week from tomorrow the 15th  of july